it's oh you're traffic
[Music]
traffic
[Applause]
blow the gate
Bill Inc block all sides of the
get
the line we need
[Applause]
[Music]
a
for that g stand by
is give a gate
C that ain't it we can walk around the
gate easily
no I don't have one I have one not a bad
[Music]
idea this
blocked Poli
[Music]
Department
we're able to get the gate this Gate's
[Music]
l
yeah I appreciate y'all coming out that
fast something was like that would have
happen but you the only one in the house
yeah only one I'm keeping the house till
they get back in
town yeah dang so there was no get
together or any kind of BS like that
here tonight so here wases my nephew
right here he out of town okay
hello
hello I I got you got the yeah the
lawyer on R Drew but um we got a police
right here he said that somebody said
cardi got shot your wife got
shot yeah I mean I'm talking to him
right now I'm in front of I got you on
speaker phone so yo this is bro my girl
we are we in
Angeles
fake F yeah we had call like this in a
long time
like this drew the
lawyer this
Drew okay yeah I'm in the house playing
a game man you know my neighbor you know
neighbor Patrick called me and said like
they said somebody got shot in the house
you you okay I like I said I'm playing
the game man like like everything's
good and I come out here man you got the
whole Call of Duty out here man I I'm
playing Call of
Duty false I mean yeah yeah it's
false they getting some information real
quick yeah hey do you have your ID on
you right now no sir I don't all right
do you have a do you have a GE driver
because it's
fake all
that we just documenting who we're
talking to my name my name I don't have
I don't got no ID though we not even
worried about any of
that yeah my name you you got an ID out
of Georgia um yeah yeah all right what's
your first name Derek Derek so d e r r i
c k it's okay it's okay
just
huh Derek d e r r i c k yes sir what's
your last name c how do you spell that c
p Huf C what
Huf one more c e p hu s h us s yes sir
what's your last uh date of
birth what's a good phone number to get
you at man
uh cooperating with us man we
just the call that came in was pretty
messy stuff yeah do y'all know who call
where the call come from well we tried
to figure it out yeah we have the number
and we tried to do you know a reverse
but we didn't have any history with that
number so we were trying to look at the
history we've had here cuz we know we
get complaints here sometimes and you
know we ain't got security no more at
gate well that's what I was asking cuz I
was I was like normally they have a guy
up there yeah yeah yeah so somebody
probably did that somebody just trying
to get it's been happening and we have
security like it's only been about four
to five days like since we have security
and this happen yeah if we had security
you like this when this going happen man
and people come by and stop all the time
and well you know that's why it's
important that we you know and I I
appreciate y'all coming out so fast and
what not I was just playing Call of Duty
and this happen but other that man
everything everything's good here man
it's quiet we appreciate it appreciate
it man all man apprciate man might have
to come on the door depending on what
the lieutenant wants to do okay it's
probably just going to be like an
information report when like be with you
the next couple minutes to figure out
our Sergeant went up there to go talk to
the lieutenant real quick so if he needs
any information but we're we're going to
document this cuz like I
said they said I uh this is my nephew I
mean this is how you know I can't this
is all right we'll get we'll we'll get
that in a second said I got wait for
something he just oh man
how we walked around it it's open no the
gate was unlocked I it open it wasn't
locked at all it was you put it open it
was like it was halfway open and it's
not it's not
like like yes I
yes but they talking they talking about
like you know somebody got s in their sh
we have all the right
exactly treat all
seriously that's all I'm saying we're
not treating anybody like a criminal but
if somebody says that they' been shot in
here we have to come and check that's
our duty to do that even
though all right man enjoy
man I got all his inform we're still
going to do a report on it all right I
appreciate it man it to
me app
it